[Musique]
chaque semaine isabel et rené se
retrouvent pour cuisiner
pendant trois heures elle prépare tous
les dîners et toutes les collations de
la semaine c'en est trop bon moment que
notre mal ce que je te rends compte
qu'on vend le poisson chat potté coeur
et au poumon une portion charlie sheen
d'ado
les boîtes à lunch de la cuisine
collective de saint-eustache sont
financés aux deux tiers par une
fondation le reste est déboursé par les
participants c'est vraiment économique
supposons que deux ans ça ça va coûter 9
$ pour les launch de la semaine de 10
enfants lors pour s'ajuster à la hausse
du prix des aliments il a fallu revoir
le budget hebdomadaire
à gérer le panier dit si justement parce
qu'il est
de 12 $ l'an dernier le budget total par
portion est passé à 15 dollars en
septembre la hausse du prix des aliments
sait quelque chose puisqu'elle en est
conscient quand même depuis plusieurs
années mais cette année je crois que ça
va et un peu plus fort
les participants cuisines collectives
ont toujours travaillé avec les rabais
de la semaine en vo avec les soulage
tant les spéciaux telle est une sorte de
viande qui sont
celles qui ne disposent pas de budget
supplémentaires doivent user d'encore
plus d'ingéniosité qu'avant ils vont
peut-être adapter leur jeu s'est réduit
à la portion de viande peut-être fait la
nage la récupération de fruits et
légumes au chili ont fait appel à des
psychologues
des clients gros
cuisiner en groupe permet d'acheter en
grande quantité et d'économiser mais ça
comporte aussi d'autres avantages donner
des idées de recettes parce que des fois
porté par des résultats au moins 10 et
parrain du monde
fort des amis de sarko et maintenant
qu'on travaille pour la maison
[Musique]
1 3 heures par semaine bien investi en
temps et en argent et c'est marie claude
morin radio canada ces deux tâches
[Musique]